so I see you're a loyal Scott plaid to
the bone I love it I love it so tell me
what do you think is important about
being a loyal Scott I think being a
loyal Scott is important because the
university is really a unique
institution I think it's part of our
obligation as alums to try and continue
that and what made you choose Carnegie
Mellon University when you first came to
college well I was looking for a really
good engineering program but a place
that had a great feel to it as well and
had a student life that would be fun
because I just didn't want to be an
engineer have you found that to be the
case that you know not only is it fun
here but also when you get involved with
your alumni group that there's smoke
some more fun people there well one of
the things I've been really amazed about
at Carnegie Mellon is that everyone's so
different and that happened in undergrad
and also happened coming back in a soul
um it's a really unique environment here
between the college of fine arts college
of humanities as well as the engineering
college everyone kind of throws in and
creates this great great kind of I don't
know kind of melange or potpourri of
different experiences and activities I
agree definitely so tell me how have you
used this in terms of like you know
getting a little edge on the other
people who have the same background as
you do but they don't have the Carnegie
Mellon experience like in the career
world well one of the things I was
really fortunate to do coming out of
Carnegie Mellon was had the opportunity
to go to Wall Street for a number of
years and one of the things i found was
that being an engineer from Carnegie
Mellon it was such a well known and
recognized school that there was an
assumption that a Carnegie Mellon
graduate represented someone who could
think well on their feet and it would
work really hard and I found that to be
the case yeah I find that to be the case
too especially when you know I talked to
great people like you so tell me how do
you show your tart and pride when you're
out there in the world well first and
foremost I think it's important having
had the benefit of this experience of
this university that I get back there's
a lot of different ways to get back you
can give back through volunteer work you
can get back obviously financially but
also you can mentor and become part of
the the Alumni Council as well and so
for me it was a matter of becoming part
of the Alumni Board and figuring out
ways to help enrich the institution